ok let's get into audience questions for
the week three great ones for you first
one relates to the 2020 primary hey
David yes there are lots of Democratic
candidates but in the end there can only
be one my question for you is how
quickly will we start to see candidates
drop out well we've already seen it
for example former West Virginia State
Senator Richard o jeta
who we interviewed on the program he's
already out pointing out he just is not
getting traction and he doesn't want
people continuing to donate to a
campaign that clearly is not going to
get off the ground so Richard oh Jetta
aside there are these new requirements
for updated requirements for what it
will take to make it onto the DNC
Democratic organized debates and those
requirements are one percent support in
three national polls 65,000 individual
donors from at least 20 different states
and a minimum of 200 unique donors from
each of those states you can't have just
65,000 donors if in one state you only
have like 10 donors you've got to have
at least 200 in each of those 20 states
but a total of 65,000 that may serve for
some of the really not well-known
candidates as a barrier to entry but as
we heard last week Andrew yang who is
one of the less well-known candidates on
the Democratic side has achieved that
and he is going to be participating some
of these really unknown can that it's
like who we've barely even been
mentioning my guess is they're not going
to make that and as a result they will
drop out probably before the debates
even start then you will probably see
after the first debate or two that
there's going to be another sort of
culling of everybody who's not getting
at least like three or four percent
support and there you're going to see
sort of another big a thinning of the
herd so to speak and then you're going
to see as we get closer and closer to
the convention that there will probably
be only three to four candidates that
are truly in the run
and there will be probably some question
about what are super-delegates going to
do will they maybe give the someone
other than the front-runner on the basis
of early primaries a possible win but
it's going to be pretty clear by that
point so I would look for who doesn't
even make it to the debates and then who
is out after the first and probably one
to three primaries before you get to
that first major primary day I think
that the the other thing to kind of
consider is that you may see four non
polling like non support reasons other
candidates drop out so there are already
discussions about there was this just
scathing report about how Amy Klobuchar
treats her staffers once making a show
out of eating a salad with a comb
because I guess they didn't bring her a
fork and then forcing them to go clean
the comb it's just all sorts of horrible
stuff it appears to be well a well
sourced article is that going to simply
push her out under the guise of it
becoming a quote distraction I got a
couple emails during the week saying
David Cory Booker is getting no traction
and he's going to be gone but before you
know it so that may also happen but I
think the first big calling will be the
debates and then the first couple of
primaries and then we will be going from
there